看看今天齐聚一堂的各位，以及我们面前的这个社区，让我回想起公司刚起步的日子。可能很多人不知道Cursor是怎么开始的，也不知道
第一版Cursor长什么样，是什么时候发布的。但作为一家人工智能公司，我们其实是从2022年1月的“史前时代”走来的。那时我们开始做这些事，而Cursor的第一个版本，其实不算太久以前，
但在AI领域，那确实是“史前时代”了。它是在2023年初发布的。公司早期其实有点走弯路，我们当时对做开发者工具和AI编程非常兴奋，
但一开始我们并没有做。原因是我们这群创始团队，其实就是四个程序员，四个非常年轻的程序员，想要做出有用的东西，但看到那些在做AI编程的人，
心里有点打鼓，觉得我们可能真的竞争不过。那时候，做AI编程的公司已经很多了，有几十家创业公司，当然还有大型科技公司。
还有那些巨头，你知道的，虽然当时它们规模还不大，现在大多了，但那些AI实验室真的让人望而生畏。我们看着2022年所有在做AI编程的人，然后
想：“没空间了，没什么可做的了，别人已经搞定了。”于是我们2022年就这么过去了，做了一系列项目，但心里一直痒痒的，放不下，忍不住
还是在年底开始做Cursor。根本原因是，我们想做一个自己真正喜欢、愿意用的工具，而市场上没有哪个产品真的符合
我们的需求。于是，我们就像一群内向、不太擅长公司经营但充满干劲的开发者那样，躲进“洞穴”，穿着内裤写了两周代码，做了个原型。
这就是我们起步的过程。最初的目标很简单，就是做一个我们能忍受使用的开发环境，至少不会让我们比用以前的工具低效两倍。我们花了几周达到了这个目标，
靠的是拼凑出一个几乎从零开始的产品，没有基于后来Cursor第一版所依赖的那些基础。我们从零搭建了一个开源代码编辑器的部分组件，
我们做了语言服务器集成、远程SSH，当时还集成了Copilot，因为产品里连自动补全都没有。然后我们做出了一个
自己能用的东西。接着我们发了一个测试版邀请名单，附上了一个联合创始人做的有点像电影特效的演示视频，吸引了一堆人报名，然后我们手动服务了前20个用户，
带他们熟悉产品，帮他们配置好，陪着他们用。第一个用户其实不太喜欢这个产品，第二个用户也不太喜欢，他们甚至直接消失了，不再联系我们。
第三个和第四个用户反应也比较冷淡，但很快我们就有了一些开发者开始使用产品，并且真的每天都用。这就开始了那个核心的
循环，在过去的疯狂岁月里我们一直遵循着：每一天我们都在想怎么让产品对自们自己更好，怎么对和我们一起建设社区的人更好。
最初那20个测试者，我们到现在还在跟他们邮件往来。社区的下一阶段是我们的Discord服务器，我们实际上雇了那个服务器里的很多成员。现在，
像这样的活动就是那个社区的自然延伸。看看我们现在在做的东西，我觉得最让我兴奋的是，经历了这一切疯狂，有一群人，
他们的核心精神就是一群为开发者而开发的开发者，这是一家非常专注于产品的公司。今天我们有三项重大发布要过一遍。在进入正题之前，
我先谈谈在过去三个月里，Cursor发生了哪些变化。变化太多了。你看，那个最初的原型，现在在我们的代码库里连一行代码、一个像素都没留下。
那些代码和界面都没了，而且这个过程发生得很快，因为代码不怎么样，界面也不怎么样，但从那以后，Cursor经历了
一次又一次的迭代。我们的目标真的是做出我们认为有用、社区开发者也觉得有用的东西，而随着技术的变化速度，这个目标已经多次调整，最近肯定也变了。
在过去几个月，我们想让Cursor变的第一个大方向是：我们希望Cursor变得更简单、更强大，特别是从根本上
为智能体工作而设计，做到“智能体优先”。这个转变其实在过去一年半里一直在进行，但我认为真正到位是在最近三个月。比如说，现在
超过95%的Cursor用户主要是把它当作智能体来用。我们的业务绝大多数都是作为编程智能体。目前，即使在请求层面，智能体的使用量也比任何辅助功能（比如）多大约5倍。
Tab键。当你控制代码行数时，代理端的使用量要高出好几个数量级。要达到这种程度，我们在产品端和构建优秀框架方面都做了大量改动。
在模型端也有许多变化，尤其是过去一两个月，随着Cursor 3的发布，人们体验Cursor的方式，即屏幕上的像素，已经发生了巨大变化。这就是
Cursor现在的样子，基本上是以代理为先。左侧有代理，中间也有代理。它结合了
致力于与代理协作的开发环境的强大功能，以及专业开发环境所应有的所有功能。所以你仍然可以编辑文件，仍然有出色的远程SSH支持，语言服务器始终运行，并
进行你期望从专业开发环境中获得的标准代码检查操作。没有任何妥协。此外，过去几个月我们为与代理协作打造了一套非常棒的专业功能。
例如，包括设计模式，你可以对着屏幕比划，指向正在构建的网页，让代理修改特定元素。这体现了更广泛的
主题，我们希望与代理协作就像与同事协作一样。你不仅可以通过文本聊天交流，还可以一起指向屏幕。Cursor 3还带有高级功能，
比如递归子代理。你可以有子代理调用子代理，拥有整个代理团队供你使用。你可以在上下文中看到一切，还有更多类似的功能。这个产品下一阶段的重要部分是
让代理能为你完成整个功能、整个错误修复和整个项目。我认为大多数开发者还没达到这个境界。大多数人，无论是在我们的产品还是在竞争工具中，
他们与代理协作，交给它们零碎的工作，大概30分钟或一小时的工作量。他们在本地电脑上运行三到五个代理，必须进行本地工具调用。这显然不是未来。
你不会让编码ASI在本地电脑上运行所有这些代理，让它们因在同一代码库上相互冲突而成为瓶颈。我们需要达到一个境界，与代理协作
就像与同事协作一样。你可以把它当作你自己的工程师团队。你需要能够交付整个项目，让代理工作数天，然后回来向你交付
完成、测试好的成果。因此，很大一部分工作是投资给代理配备自己的计算机，让这种体验特别简单、特别快捷、特别强大。所以云
得到了重大升级和一系列性能改进，也是Cursor 3的重要组成部分。Cursor的另一个重大变化是从第一方产品，即人类与之交互的封闭世界系统，转变为真正的
平台。编程代理是团队的基础设施，是业务的基础设施。它们也是当今每个人的编码方式。对于如此核心工作、如此核心
团队工作的工具，你需要能够修改它。你可以编辑它，并控制你想要的各个方面。所以我们很高兴宣布我们的SDK。我们认为非常重要的一点是，
Cursor不仅可以让人类直接通过产品交互使用，还可以通过最佳UX和正式编程语言访问，也可以被其他代理访问。可黑客性
构建平台不仅来自SDK，还来自于让Cursor使用你所使用的所有工具。当我们努力让代理像同事一样工作时，你需要能够使用工程师使用的相同工具。
所以它们需要能在DataDog中搜索，或者从数据库提取数据，或者使用你能访问的相同设计工具。我们很高兴看到人们为Cursor构建的插件空间日益扩大，
既有内部临时为自有工具构建的，也有用户群广泛使用的热门工具。此外，让Cursor更具可扩展性和可定制性的一个重要组成部分是加大对
CLI的投入。过去几个月，我们对命令行进行了超过50项质量和体验改进，你可以在无头模式下使用，也可以将其作为独立界面。我们认为
Cursor在你需要它的任何地方都可用非常重要，比如在网页上、桌面应用上，但很多时候你总会想要使用终端界面。最后，过去几个月我们的一个重点是
构建模型。这是我们公司创立之初就开始做的事情。在2023年，第一个黑客松原型不久之后，你知道，20个Beta测试者中有18个
踢着脚尖叫着逃跑了。由于某种原因，我们从用户群得到的信心让我们雄心勃勃，开始研究模型。2023年从Tab模型开始。我们
在2023年和2024年发布的一系列Tab模型，我认为它们实际上是那些年里一些最受欢迎的编码模型，写了世界上很多代码。我们旅程的下一个进展是
做模型其实是为了让第一批原型智能体在2024年和2025年跑起来。我们当时通过改造API模型，建立小型替代模型来修补它们的弱点。
比如它们不会调用工具，或在代码库里搜索时，我们就训练模型来赋予这些能力。但过去一年里，我们的目标大了很多，我们开始研究
智能体编程模型，就是那种基础模型，能执行所有你想让Cursor做的事。这就是我们的作曲家系列模型，从作曲家一号开始，
2025年11月发布。有了作曲家一号，我们能在关心的任务上大规模强化学习。我们开始时用开源基础模型，可能大家都知道，然后投入大量计算资源，
让它对开发者更有用。后来我们用同样方法扩展到了作曲家1.5。到了作曲家2，有两个重大转变。一是让持续预训练跑通，
不只是强化学习，还要在开源模型上训练数万亿tokens。另一个是实现实时强化学习。所以，模型每5小时更新一次，在线学习用户喜欢什么、不喜欢什么，
模型哪里高效、哪里低效。然后我们用作曲家2.5进一步扩展。我们看到作曲家模型火速获得关注，真的很受鼓舞。
这源于一些因素。目前来看，我觉得主要靠速度和成本。这对我们至关重要。我们觉得，如果模型很强大，
但只有大公司能负担得起，普通用户和开发者都被挡在门外，那会是个很可悲的世界。我们不想那样。
我们希望个体开发者、独立黑客们，能用上市场上最顶尖的模型。所以，我们最近在作曲家模型系列上大力优化成本和速度。
我们看到大家开始意识到，稳定状态下，适当用上几个模型是有道理的。也许日常用性价比高的，偶尔用更贵的，
当其有意义时。我得说，我们的目标是打造整体上最强、最有用的编程模型。但很高兴看到速度和成本的优势开始被认可。所以，接下来
我们有三项重大发布，关于我们正在开发的新功能。话不多说，直接交给负责我们一个产品团队的Kevin。
谢谢Michael。今天我想聊聊我们如何将编程带出笔记本电脑。就像我们在Fable和这些早期代理系统中看到的，代理很快将能运行
不仅几小时，而是几天甚至几周。如果你把这看作关键基础设施，你的代理需要一直在线、始终运行。我们不会在笔记本电脑上运行生产服务器，
这是有原因的。你真正想要的是，正如Michael提到的，一个可以随时求助的队友——无论你是外出拜访客户、跑步，还是睡前突然冒出灵感。一个你可以
求助的队友，他能实际去实现那个功能请求，让它成真，并在灵感闪现时交付一个完全生产化的版本。我们一直在开发云代理来实现这一点。
我想谈谈在设计云代理时我们思考的几个原则。首先，云代理需要自主。它们需要始终在线，并且能在任何地方工作。所以，我们在
这三个不同维度上都有一些令人兴奋的更新。为了让代理自主，我们给了它们自己的开发环境。这样它们就能像你们一样工作。它们有自己的电脑和资源，所以能真正测试
它们正在编写的代码，能交付演示，并像你们构建软件时一样行动。那么，开发环境中包含什么呢？嗯，有几个不同的组件。首先是，显然，
代理需要代码。所以，它们需要克隆仓库、安装依赖、获取凭证以访问构建系统和内部工具链。另一方面，这解锁了
代理能为你做的新能力。它们可以运行测试、验证工作、生成截图等，你可以直观地交互、圈出、描述并继续提示。所以，
这比你可能习惯使用的代理要互动性强得多。在我身后，你可以看到在云端自主工作的代理能做什么。它生成了刚完成工作的演示。你可以
查看它、圈出它、与它互动。当代理拥有自己的开发环境时，一切都变得真实多了。第二，代理需要始终在线。我们正从提示代理工作转向一个
循环和代理系统的时代，代理将始终代表我们工作。它们会以编程方式启动，甚至可能比我们提示它们更频繁地提示我们。这只有在速度非常快的情况下才可能实现。
打造真正可靠的智能体，说到底是个硬核基础设施难题，我们也是撞了南墙才明白的。过去几个月，我们把云端智能体的速度提了三倍，可靠性也达到了三个九。
我们的终极目标，就是给你配一个这样的队友——一个靠谱的云端智能体，带着它的开发环境，帮你搞定所有这些炫酷的新活儿。这些性能和可靠性的提升，真正发威的时候是——
你的智能体全天候为你待命。我们搞了自动化工具和SDK，让这些工作流搭建、部署都特别省事，还能在后台跑。我最喜欢的一个自动化案例来自客户Amplitude，他们现在正——
忙着迁移两万个React组件实例，把它们挨个换成Tailwind版本。整个活儿全靠一个定制迁移智能体在后台跑，这是他们——
在Cursor上搭好并部署的。不只是Amplitude，自从几个月前上线自动化产品以来，我们已经跑了超过六百万次自动化任务。最后，你无论在哪儿，都得能跟你的智能体协作——
现在，你可以在最熟悉的那些应用里直接启动智能体，不管是跟同事在Slack或Microsoft Teams里聊着，还是Jira或Linear里蹦出个新工单。我们还开放了云端——
API和Webhooks，方便你随时调用这些云端智能体。当然，你也能在多个界面里跟它们协同，就像Michael演示的，从我们的新智能体窗口，到你的编辑器、IDE、命令行——
还有终端。今天，我们特别兴奋地推出Cursor Mobile的测试版。它彻底改变了我们‘用Cursor造Cursor’的方式。有了Cursor Mobile，你随时随地都能跟智能体协作，帮它们解围，——
迸发新点子，想在哪写就在哪写。你能看到所有智能体的运行状态，知道哪些卡住了，还能连上你所有的代码仓库。而且，智能体——
产出的东西你也能看到。它生成简短、可核对的截图，方便你在手机上随时查看。哪里看着不对劲，你直接在截图上一圈，就能给智能体下指令，让它们接着干活儿。还有——
对于那些想继续在本地工作的朋友，可能你桌上现在堆了一排Mac mini，或者你就是喜欢半开笔记本到处跑的那种人，Cursor Mobile也支持远程控制，让你在外头也能——
指挥本地的智能体。今天，在座的各位就能用上iOS版的Cursor。我看大家都在掏手机了。扫我身后这个二维码，就能参加TestFlight测试，——
再过几天，我们就会向全世界开放。我们特别期待看到大家用Cursor Mobile能造出什么新东西，也期待看到大家会在哪里开始创作。接下来，有请——
Tamas来聊聊我们正在开发的另一个面。
谢谢Kevin。大家好，今天能站在这里，我特别激动。我叫Tamas，是Graphite的联合创始人之一，今年一月跟着Graphite一起加入了Cursor。在座凡是——
带过团队写代码的都知道，软件开发远不止写代码那么简单。测试、评审、合并、部署，样样少不了。在Graphite，我们做的就是打造最顶尖的工具，把这些环节加速。我们服务着——
最优秀也最挑剔的工程团队，比如Shopify、Snowflake、Notion、Figma，还有一大堆别的公司。他们每天靠我们的工具，让开发者在这些关键工作流里跑得又稳又快。
不过，这几年我们发现一个趋势：随着这些公司用上AI工具，他们原本依赖的那些工具就开始不顶用了。原因就是，AI工具这几年把整个行业都掀了个底朝天，它——
让每个开发者都成了10倍甚至100倍效率的开发者，但这样的变化，需要完全不同的工具来配套。所以，我们被Cursor收购后，就加速推进了最野心勃勃的项目——从零开始重建这些工具。
今天，我特别高兴地宣布：Origin，一个为智能体而生的Git平台。有了Origin，你——
谢谢。有了Origin，你和你的智能体可以在同一个熟悉的生态里建仓库、分享代码、管理改动。它天生就为规模而生，也够灵活，能让代码流转得飞快。我们来聊聊——
‘智能体原生’到底意味着什么。我们坐下来琢磨这事儿的时候，脑子里蹦出来的第一个词是‘规模’。随着开发者用上这种AI工具，我们看到代码量、——
提交数、拉取请求，都指数级增长。所以我们回到原点，重新设计了一套全新的Git架构，把云服务商提供的基础能力用到了极致，换来更好的可扩展性、可靠性和性能，这样才能——
跟上这些变化的需求。在早期的负载测试里，我们模拟了上千个智能体同时干活，结果发现，我们能在同一个仓库上同时push和pull，性能足够应对现在的需求，也撑得住——
未来预期。测试结果漂亮得惊人，让我们有信心说，Origin就是一块坚如磐石的Git基础设施，为规模而生，既能满足人的规模，也能满足智能体的规模。第二个想到的词是‘可扩展’。
正如迈克尔刚才所说，Cursor是一个平台。因此，当我们开始思考构建一个原生代理的Git平台意味着什么时，我们的第一个想法是，我们必须让它能够让你在上面构建任何你想要的东西。
通过我们的API、MCP以及第三方应用平台，你和你的代理可以使用Origin来做任何适合你的事情。凭借慷慨的速率限制和全面的API，你完全掌控自己的数据。关于Origin的第三件事是，我们构建它是为了让代码持续流动。
由驱动Cursor的相同智能技术支持，Origin可以解决合并冲突、修复CI失败并处理评论。它会自动为每个PR找出下一步行动，并且只在需要时通知你。
通过利用代理来修复和审查PR，它能将代码审查时间减少一半以上，保持代码流动。Origin已经在cursor.com上线，目前面向内部和选定的设计合作伙伴，并将在今年秋季向所有人推出。
如果你有兴趣与我们一起构建协作软件开发的美好未来，请在cursor.com/origin上加入等待名单。谢谢，接下来把麦克风交还给迈克尔。
谢谢托马斯。最后再公布一个消息。今天我们要聊的不只是产品本身，还有我们的下一代模型。我们非常高兴地宣布，我们正在训练的这款模型，和以往任何一款都大不相同。
它有三个不同之处。首先，它规模庞大，和OpenAI的GPT系列相当。第二，它是从零开始训练的，不是基于开源模型。我们热爱开源，也希望能有更多方式回馈开源社区，但从零开始能让我们完全掌控模型的行为，更好地针对我们和你们关心的任务进行调优。
还有最关键的一点，我们正在使用10到……
我们现在的计算能力是以前的20倍。我们上一个模型用的算力比之前多一些，但这真的是第一个大幅扩展算力的模型。这事儿意义非凡，非常非常重大。
因为以前，我们的Composer模型，从Composer 1到Composer 2.5，都是在相对于前沿实验室来说很少的GPU上训练的。这真的限制了你能做什么。我们为了让模型越来越好所做的努力，根本上的瓶颈就是能不能用更多GPU跑更长时间。
所以，这次10到20倍的算力扩展，我们觉得真的能让我们达到前沿水平，而且希望很快能实现超越。
而且要为你们所有人带来激动人心的新功能。最后，这将是不仅仅局限于编程的智能模型。我们认为这对Cursor未来的发展至关重要。我们想让
任何人都能在电脑上构建他们想要的东西。而瓶颈不再仅仅是编写代码，而是你期望从工程师同事那里获得的一切。
这意味着使用工程师会使用的工具，意味着长远规划，意味着实际测试软件、点击按钮，也意味着出色的用户体验，清晰展示代理到底做了什么更改。
但我们将超越编程，让这个模型更加通用智能。我们正在深入训练中，已经启动，将在未来几周内发布。这一切都得到了
我们与SpaceX的合作支持，大家都知道这不仅仅是合作。最近新闻不多。我认为这不仅对这个项目令人兴奋，也对我们期待的下一代模型发布令人兴奋，
同时也呼应了我们开始时所谈论的。在AI领域，能真正协同设计产品和模型的机构屈指可数。我认为其他玩家的
基本公司基因都是大型科技公司，或者从实验室起步然后转向开发者和构建者领域。而这家公司，
无论好坏，我认为是更好的，真正以开发者为核心。这是我们的起点，也是我们关心的。这家公司本质上由那些想为自己
打造有用工具的人组成。因此，公司的下一阶段，我认为首次提升了一群拥有这种产品精神、开发者精神的核心团队，并赋予他们能力，不仅
能编辑屏幕上的像素，还能编辑模型的基本能力，这是产品的重要部分。所以，我对这次发布以及未来几个月即将看到的一系列发布
感到非常兴奋。好了，这就是我要宣布的三大消息：今天发布的移动应用、开始挑战GitHub，以及我们首次透露的新模型预览。
还有我们未来的模型计划。谢谢。